Speaker 1: so radical repugnant Republican
Congresswoman Lauren Boebert or Boebert
depending on your preference. Spoke at the Turning
Point event over the weekend in Tampa, Florida.
She apropos of seemingly nothing, although there
actually is a back story but nobody knew it,
she denied being a prostitute for Ted Cruz.
Now it's not clear whether she means that
Ted Cruz was her pimp and that's what she's
denying or that Ted Cruz was the john and
that's what she is then I don't know which
she's denying, but she is denying it. Check
this out. This is a congresswoman, folks.
Speaker 2: What about Ted Cruz lately in
the news and contrary to popular belief. I've
never been an escort for a Senator Ted Cruz.
But I will tell you tonight, it is
the coolest thing I've ever heard
about Ted Cruz.
Speaker 1: At the time,
she was not a prostitute for Ted Cruz. And whether
that means with Ted Cruz as the client or Ted Cruz
as the pimp. But regardless, it would be cool
if Ted Cruz was doing that. I guess it's all
very strange. Now, this actually does relate
to something. This story did not get a lot of
attention. It was the story was pitched to me and
I didn't cover it because the sourcing on it was
sketchy and just didn't make sense to cover it.
There was a group that made claims about Lauren
Boebert, including that she was an escort or
prostitute and it was not. You know, when I
looked at it, it didn't look like Lauren Boebert
in the picture. And indeed, CNN said the woman
in the picture is not boebert. And there were all
sorts of other incorrect claims made, but it was
not really a widely known story. So her bringing
up and saying, listen, let me just tell you,
I was not an escort. Okay. Just kind of a weird
moment. One other kind of interesting moment is
when Lauren Boebert put together a very strange
word salad that was completely unintelligible.
See if you can make heads or tails out of this.
Unidentified: I'll position yourself for this
newness and this new myth that we are coming into.
Speaker 2: We are going to take our country back
together. We are not drawing back. We
are pressing in every single day. That's
why you're here getting equipped for that.
Speaker 1: Right. If you can understand that,
please email me and explain to me what
she's saying about positioning yourself
for the new ness, the newness, the new ness.
Crazy, crazy conference. And the crowd will cheer
for anything. After the break, we'll
look at one more clip from this event
from Matt Gaetz and then move on to other
things. Stay with us. We'll be right back.